it's the day of the final cook and I
should be getting my fires going good
morning this is B 4 how are you but I
have a lead on one more special
ingredient that I'm told can be
harvested nearby what is this secret
ingredient Phegley Sydney
multi-divisional Sydney market ID she's
making a chutney out of the Weaver ant
that's a delicacy Weaver ants yes rice
it's spicy it's salty and it's odd that
sounds like your unique chutney and
where are these ants right up there
that's what we were looking at what
could Mariana Kira quietly shake more
bacon okay she says that he's gonna
shine up the tree lot that branch off
drop their ants down right into a
assignment to have a rope for him this
this is the ladder that his bloody nails
it's like a bamboo stick be careful um
he's sure that bamboo is strong enough
it's it's definitely strong enough for
him it's not even tied onto the trees
pretty adept at this bloody hell this is
crazy I mean really crazy there he's
already on the tree now he's on the tree
getting it yeah they know the hills they
know the jungles yes they're very very
good at this that is incredible what a
performance
getting the ants I mean you know I'll go
to hell him back here to get the best
ingredients but that is a different
ballgame
thank you so take this he's gonna try
and hold the nest oh gosh let me come
left
okay can go to the right I look like I'm
attempting the most Awkward tick-tock
dance ever that bag you and you're
swaying left to right bang I missed it
and then all of a sudden they're
everywhere man and just when you think
you've got the last one you put hands in
your pockets in there I think I got half
of the ants in my pants
pick out any dust these little bits
along the way that's the the eggs
what while most of the ants are making a
meal on my nether region the rest are
getting chucked into the chutney first
you have to put the coconut in
everything to make the chutney we mix
coconut garlic salt coriander seeds and
of course chili powder all of it yeah
then we add the ants some water and
grind watch that you don't smash your
fingers yeah
you're doing good she says
Wow it's delicious
Oh lovely it's very fresh yes vibrant
chutney
I love chutneys that for me has to be
the most fragrant slightly bitter but
with the addition of that coconut meal
in there mmm delicious
what a delicacy and for me a great
addition to my final meal I don't think
these ladies are expecting that from me
today so a little lace card up my sleeve
fingers crossed
want to see more for my uncharted
adventures please click here to watch
more clips